BUSSEY: Welcome everybody.
We're going to go a few minutes later than
planned, to about 9:20, and we'll have a good
opportunity for a robust question-and-answer
session.
So, please, be thinking of some robust questions
as we go along in our conversation this morning.
Just a reminder that this is on the record.
When you ask your questions later on, I'll
just be asking you to identify yourself.
If you can put your ringers off on your cellphones,
just put it on stun, you know, whatever setting
you have, that would be very helpful to us.
And since we have a lot to talk about, let's
jump right into it.
Secretary Lew, thank you very much for joining
us.
This feels like an historic week.
It's not quite like a moon landing, but we
appear to be very close to having a budget,
which is -- seems an unusual thing for the
United States of America.
It's not without a stopgap or so, but it looks
like this is going to move fairly quickly
now.
I wonder if you can talk about how this might
affect business confidence, consumer confidence,
going into the 2014 calendar economic year,
how it affects your outlook on growth in the
U.S.?
But also do so in the context, if you would,
of this -- the strange number we got on jobs
in December, which seemed like it was out
of the ordinary from the trend line, which
had been quite positive before, a weak jobs
number in December, if that was an anomaly
or if there was something that worries you
in it.
LEW: Well, John, it's good to be here.
Thanks so much for doing this.
I think we're starting the year off strong.
We're starting the year off with economic
tailwinds, not headwinds, and I'll get back
to the specific number you asked about.
And I think we're starting out with Congress
following through on the end of last year,
which was trying to get back to some kind
of normalcy and away from the kind of brinksmanship
and uncertainty that was causing a great deal
of impact to confidence in the United States
and internationally.
Obviously, we're, you know, not out of the
woods completely.
We still have a lot more to do to keep our
economy growing.
But if you look at the arc of the last half-year,
the trend of economic statistics -- job statistics,
confidence -- have been strong.
It's been strong across sectors.
And there's potential for more growth in a
number of key areas.
I do think that the mood in Washington makes
a difference, in two different ways.
One, the policy actually matters.
The fact is that the budget agreement, which
is now being implemented through these appropriation
bills, takes away some of the fiscal drag
from the economy.
That actually matters.
Macroeconomics matter.
And going from policies that push back on
economic growth to creating a little bit more
economic energy help.
But the question of business-as-usual versus
dysfunction is extremely significant.
Just a few months ago, we had a government
shutdown, we were in the midst of a crisis
over the borrowing authority of the United
States, and it was very undermining of confidence.
Now, the reason I say we're not out of the
woods completely is that as long as we still
have so many Americans looking for work, our
job is to focus on more growth and more jobs,
and we still have some deadlines ahead of
us here in Washington.
We have, you know, a deadline looming in February.
February 7th our borrowing authority runs
out again.
At that point, Congress has to act to get
the borrowing authority.
BUSSEY: We'll get to -- we'll get -- we'll
come around to that.
Tell us a little bit about December, though,
about what happened with the jobs number.
LEW: So it -- I've spent most of the last
three-and-a-half decades advising policymakers
not to react to each month-to-month number
too strongly, to look at the overall pattern.
We will only know in several months exactly
what that number means.
I've read an enormous range of views as to
what the number means.
I think you have to look at the kind of trend
that has been clear for several months, and
I don't think that one ought to look at a
number that deviates from that as being in
and of itself proof that -- that there's been
a fundamental change.
Economies don't turn on a dime, so all of
the evidence that there was strength in the
economy is still there.
And, you know, our job is to make sure we
promote more growth.
Our job is to make sure we promote more investment.
There are things we can do.
You know, there's a debate in Washington now
about whether or not to extend unemployment
benefits.
You can look at that in two different ways,
and both are right.
One, it's a question of just simple fairness,
people looking for work, you know, out of
work because of the deep recession that we
took a long time to come out of, they need
the help.
You can also look at it as a macroeconomic
question.
All those people who are looking for work
are also putting food on the table and taking
care of the necessities of life, and every
penny that they get, they spend.
And that's economic activity.
So I hope that we get back to the discussion
of how to extend unemployment benefits.
We can get in the discussion to other questions
of things that we can do, but, you know, the
more we do consistent with the spirit of the
budget agreement that takes step after step
to make progress, the better the economy's
going to be.
You look at the budget agreement, there are
actually some things in there that, as people
focus on them, you know, there's funding for
manufacturing centers.
There's funding for early childhood education.
There are things in there that are going to
be good for today and for the future of the
American economy, and we can continue to take
steps along that path.
What the infrastructure needs in this country,
it would help in the short term, it would
help in the long term.
BUSSEY: So there have been a lot of good numbers
in the last several months, a pretty healthy
trajectory.
Manufacturing growth, export growth, November
numbers were really good.
One number in December that was consistent
with previous months is the erosion of -- of
the denominator in the unemployment calculation,
that is, people leaving the workforce, giving
up looking for work.
How does that affect your growth forecast
for 2014?
Are you still on the -- is it still expected
to be in the 2 percent, you know, range for
the calendar year?
LEW: Well, we'll obviously come out with our
new economic projections in a few weeks when
-- when the budget comes out.
I'm not going to kind of lift the curtain
early on them, except to say that we ended
the year...
BUSSEY: Just do that here.
I mean, we'll keep it just between us.
(LAUGHTER)
LEW: We -- we ended the year with -- with
confidence that the economy was doing better,
and we start the year with confidence that
it's continuing to do better.
You know, the long-term unemployment numbers,
the labor force participation rate numbers,
they're very serious issues that we spend
a lot of time poring over and asking what's
causing it, what are the policy responses.
There are a lot of, again, competing explanations,
some of them demographic, some of them cyclical,
some of them structural...
BUSSEY: People getting older and leaving the
workforce normally.
LEW: People are getting older, and there's
some normal transitions going on.
It's been a long, slow recovery from a very
deep financially-led recession, so there's
a delay in some of the employment growth.
But it's that structural piece that we have
to worry about.
We really have to ask ourselves, if somebody
graduated from high school or college and
didn't go to work and didn't get right into
the labor force, what can we do to make it
easier for them to get started?
What can we do to take away the skill gap
that may be preventing them from getting started?
And, frankly, what can we do to work with
employers to take away some of stigma that
is associated with not having worked for a
period of time?
You know, if you graduated college or high
school when unemployment was, you know, close
to 10 percent, it was really hard to get that
first job.
And the fact that you're now delayed in getting
started is something we have to worry about,
how do you catch up?
And, you know, frankly, that's something that's
a question of public policy, but it's also
a question of working with the private sector
to make sure that employers are thinking about,
how do we give those kids a chance?
BUSSEY: So you mentioned February 7th.
That's yet another potential stumbling block
for the economy, another point of uncertainty.
It's the debt ceiling deadline.
Having been through this drama a couple of
times now in the last couple of years, and
seeing the effect on confidence, the economy,
the markets, wouldn't it be in the Treasury's
interest to say, look, here's our battle plan.
If this thing goes to the wire again, if it's
a cliffhanger, these are our priorities for
spending, this is how we're going to martial
our funds, we'll buy enough time past the
end of February, not just for a couple of
weeks, to see the economy through, don't worry,
markets, don't worry, business investment,
don't worry, consumer?
LEW: Well, John, I don't think any treasury
secretary of either party has ever said, "Don't
worry about what happens if the United States
loses its capacity to borrow," because it's
something to worry about.
We -- if we ever get to the place where the
United States cannot keep all of its obligations,
we are fundamentally hurting our -- our standing
as a country that has always honored all of
its obligations.
So I actually don't believe that there is
any plan that could give the kind of confidence
that you're describing.
You know, people ask legalistic questions
about, what do you have the ability to do?
And I'm asking the more fundamental question,
why would anyone want to hurt the U.S. economy
and hurt the recipients of payments that they're
entitled to because of a self-inflicted wound,
because of something that -- everyone knows
that the obligations are not made when the
borrowing authority is raised.
The obligations are being made when you vote
on appropriation bills, when you vote on tax
bills.
In the end, the borrowing authority merely
allows you to operate under the policy decisions
you've made.
Congress...
BUSSEY: It's spending you've already done.
LEW: Yeah, spending, the combination of policies.
Now, I -- this is Congress's unique responsibility.
Congress is going to have to act.
It is not, I think, something that anyone
should want to repeat, the kind of, you know,
hair-raising brinksmanship that causes real
uncertainty and anxiety in, you know, market
participants and normal, you know, consumers.
I mean, when you -- if you went outside of
Washington in October, it didn't take very
much to get people to be worried about what
was happening and what was going to happen.
You know, people worry about what happens
if payments aren't made, what happens if there's
an economic fallout that undermines their
stability, their employment.
These are not things that Congress should
play games with.
It has to be done.
The sooner, the better.
You know, I think we get into a kind of Washington
parlor sport of trying to figure out the precise
moment when, when is the last minute?
It's a mistake to go to the last minute.
The build-up to the last minute causes damage.
It's a mistake to wait until the 11th hour.
Congress should do this as quickly as possible
and as -- with the least drama as possible.
And I will say that, in terms of how long
Congress has, you know, we -- I've communicated
with Congress, saying we thought that the,
you know, ability to manage through the debt
limit being hit on February 7th would get
us maybe to the end of February or early March.
It's a very unpredictable time of year in
terms of cash flow, because people are filing
for tax refunds.
And when you start paying tax refunds, it's
a time of year when money goes out.
You know, a month later, when people are paying
their taxes, money comes in.
You cannot get from here to there without
extending the debt limit.
And I think that if Congress is looking at
the numbers the way we are -- we have the
best data -- they would see that they would
be looking more at the end of February than
any time in March...
(CROSSTALK)
BUSSEY: Tighter timeframe than in the past.
LEW: Yeah.
BUSSEY: So let's talk a little bit about the
global economy, since that has such an impact
on the health of the U.S. economy.
You have just been recently in Europe.
You did a trip to China and Japan and Asia
a couple of months ago, were in Europe before
that.
You've been counseling the Europeans, particularly
the Germans, to spend more domestically as
opposed to revive their economies by exports.
That sounds a little bit like John Snow saying
the same thing to China a few years ago, that
you need to build up your domestic economy.
The Germans kind of said, you know, "Leave
us alone, mind your own business," when you
said that.
Can you -- can you walk through for us what's
happening, starting with Europe?
Is the crisis now abating to the point where
you can see growth organically?
LEW: I think if you look at Europe now compared
to Europe in 2012, there's been a huge amount
of progress.
You know, we -- we don't have to worry from
day-to-day about -- about a half-a-dozen countries.
But they're not completely out of the woods.
They're looking at having turned the corner
from minus to either neutral or small positive.
There's inconsistency.
There's fragmentation in the financial markets.
There's different -- very different rates
of potential growth and growth in different
countries.
Our message in Europe has been that you need
to do what you can do to get overall growth
in Europe to a higher level, understanding
that not every country has an equal capacity,
that there are surplus countries that have
the capacity to invest more and to create
more domestic demand, and that would be good
for Europe's economy, it would be good for
the global economy.
I'd take a step back and just put the pieces
into some perspective, because this is how
I think about the global economic recovery.
You know, we're now in -- you know, in a growth
place that many in the world envy.
You know, we're in the twos.
People are talking about, can we get three?
You know, they're trying to get to one.
You know, there's a decimal point behind the
numbers they're looking at.
You know, in our most optimistic projections,
we can't make up for Europe falling half a
point or a point behind where it should be.
We can't make up for China falling a half
a point or a point behind where it should
be.
So as I talk to my colleagues around the world,
I say we're going to do our part.
We're going to keep our economy growing.
We're going to shoot to hit growth targets
that -- that outperform people's expectations.
But you have to do the same.
So in Europe, that means countries that have
surplus doing some more to stimulate investment
in demand.
Frankly, you know, I think if you look at
the German coalition agreement and the policies
they're putting in place, they are doing more.
They've made a commitment to invest in infrastructure
this year.
I wish we could make a commitment like that
here; it would be good for the United States,
as well.
You know, you look over the arc of the last
year, last February, March, April, the discussion
was, should countries in Europe that have
to meet fiscal consolidation targets do it
more quickly or over a longer time horizon?
They've eased the time horizon.
So I think we've made progress.
And I think if you look at the questions on
banking reform, they've made progress.
But in each of these cases, there's more to
do.
So our conversations are -- you know, we do
have friendly differences of view on occasion,
but I think, A, they have impact, and, B,
we are pushing for more, because more is good
for them and it's good for us.
You flip to China, it's pretty much the same
story.
When I meet with my Chinese counterparts,
I am pretty confident that they are intent
on the path of economic reform that they describe.
At the same time, I am not confident about
the timeframe or which targets of opportunity
will be sequenced early in the queue.
And we -- we continue to bring an awful lot
of focus on the need for market-determined
exchange rates, on competitive market determination
of allocation and price of capital.
And I think that they are going to move in
that direction, and our interventions will
be designed to speed that process up.
Again, it's good for China's economy.
I don't think we are asking either Europe
or China to do things that aren't in their
own interest.
BUSSEY: But let's come back to China a second
and stay on Europe just for a minute longer.
One of the areas that still needs to be resolved
is financial regulatory reform.
We're five years now after -- after the crisis.
And still there's fundamental disagreement
within Europe, and between Europe and the
United States, over banking requirements,
the levels of reserves, even executive pay,
disagreements between Britain and the rest
of Europe, and Europe with the U.S.
Why can't this be resolved?
We are five years into the -- you know, after
the crisis.
Europe needs to have that confidence in its
banking system for its economic well-being.
Is this financial protectionism, financial
regulatory protectionism, in a kind of way,
playing out, we don't want to restrict our
banks if you're not going to do the same thing?
LEW: You know, this is very difficult stuff.
And I think we in the United States have made
enormous progress.
Even in this last year, we've made enormous
progress implementing financial reform.
I think internationally we have made and are
continuing to make progress.
I know my objective in the G-20 this year
is going to be to bring some additional focus
to the international...
BUSSEY: You're meeting next month, in February...
(CROSSTALK)
LEW: Yeah, the first meting is -- is next
-- in February in Australia.
But, you know, the G-20 and the financial
stabilization board are the places where the
international community comes together to
have conversations about harmonizing standards.
You know, just this last weekend, some significant
progress was made in terms of international
standards on capital and leverage.
You know, for the last year, there's been
an argument about whether or not our differences
were as big as people said or not as big,
because of differences in the way we calculate
it.
And I must say, as somebody who likes to be
able to compare apples to apples, when you
have conversations where people are talking
past each other because, you know, one is
looking at a set of numbers on a net basis
and the other is looking at them on a gross
basis, and trying to do the conversion in
your head is almost impossible, there was
an agreement to do it on a standardized basis
following the rule that our regulators put
in place in draft rules earlier in the year.
I think that opens the path for the United
States to finalize rules in a way that's consistent
with international standards.
And I made clear that, as we engage in conversations
internationally, we cannot weaken standards
to get to international harmonization.
This has to be a race to the top, not a race
to the bottom.
But we should try to harmonize them to eliminate
confusion, especially where the confusion
is related to technical differences, as opposed
to policy differences.
You know, when I look at the challenges ahead,
I also look at what we've accomplished.
That's much more capital in the United States
banks and in global banks.
We've put in place a resolution program that
is something that the world is now seeing
as a model, where we do stress tests, we have
living wills, we have a single point of entry
in the event of a failure.
And we're seeing those become things that
the world -- you know, other regulators around
the world are trying to put in place.
We have one country, you know, so we pass
rules, we have multiple regulators, and it's
sometimes a challenge to get our regulators
to the same place, but we've been doing, you
know, a lot of work to get our regulators
to consistently put forth standards in these
areas.
You go to Europe, and you have, you know,
multiple countries and multiple legislatures
that have to take action after there's an
agreement in the larger group.
So we're very sympathetic to the challenges
of coming up with policies.
You know, at the end of the year, the progress
that was made in Europe on banking reform
put in place a mechanism that is new and important.
I mean, it is a path towards over a period
of years having a fund that banks contribute
to that's loosely modeled on our FDIC.
We don't think it's big enough; we don't think
it's fast enough.
As I look to the future, the challenges of
2014 and beyond have to deal not with what
were the risks in 2008, but what are the risks
in 2014 and beyond?
And we're focusing heavily on issues like
shadow banking.
Those are issues the global financial community...
BUSSEY: Banking that happens outside of official
banking.
LEW: Banking outside of the -- the regulated
banking system.
You know...
BUSSEY: Right, right.
Money sloshing around that's kind of not controllable.
LEW: Yeah, it -- there's a natural shift of
money from the more controlled environment
to the less controlled environment, and the
risks are not always as visible because of
a lighter regulatory presence and because
of a lower set of requirements.
So that's an area that we're focusing on.
I think my international colleagues also are
focusing on it.
And I think we can make -- we have made progress.
We could make more progress.
Cross-border resolution, this gets to your
question about the differences of standards.
You know, I think we learned from the collapse
of Lehman that, you know, the problems when
a major financial institution fails are not
-- don't respect international boundaries.
The transactions don't live within one country;
the implications don't live within one country.
It's very important that there be confidence
that when an institution fails, if an institution
fails, that the resolution internationally
works, because that's the way you can avoid
the domino effect that -- that is an accelerant
to a financial and economic crisis.
I think we have more work to do there.
We've made progress; we need to make more
progress.
BUSSEY: Just on China for a moment, before
we get to trade, and then I want to get to
questions in just a second.
You mentioned China's economic reform program.
So far, we've heard a fair amount of discussion
of this, and it's going to focus heavily on
developing out the private sector of China.
Xi Jinping has said as much.
Is that good or bad for American business?
Is that something that's going to be more
inclusive of U.S. business or are we seeing
the cultivation of national champions in -- in
China to the continued exclusion -- it's not
entirely -- but to the continued exclusion
of a lot of involvement from the U.S.?
This anti-monopoly law, using the anti-monopoly
law right now to hammer foreign businesses
is reminiscent of the indigenous innovation
problems that American businesses have.
So it doesn't feel like the situation's changing
there much.
LEW: Well, the goal has to be to open markets
and to have market forces determine the answer
to the question that you're asking.
If there are artificial barriers in place,
then it's not really letting market forces
work.
I think we will get some tests pretty soon.
You know, when we had our Strategic and Economic
Dialogue last summer, we had a set of important
agreements come out of it.
I was very pleased that China moved on opening
a Shanghai free trade zone.
They moved on altering a decades-long policy
of presuming industries were closed to foreign
activity to presuming that they're open unless
individually closed.
We've yet to see what the implementation of
those policies look like.
So if the Shanghai free trade zone opens up
to real competition, for example, to U.S.
financial firms, that will be a meaningful
signal.
As they go through the designations of what's
open and what's closed, if you designate everything
as closed, it doesn't amount to real change.
It's still early.
The direction of the policies that they announced
in the third plenum was consistent with what
they agreed to in our bilateral discussions.
I think that they know that the -- it's critical
to the Chinese economy to let market forces
drive much more, if not all, major economic
policy.
They look at state-owned enterprises, and
they see built-up inventory that has nowhere
to go.
They see empty buildings.
They know that that is not a way to maintain
the growth that they need for China to be
where it needs to be in 2014, '15 and beyond.
Now, at the same time, transition is difficult
in any economy.
It's difficult in our economy; it's difficult
in their economy.
So they are obviously concerned about the
pace at which change happens and managing
it.
But trying to stop it would be very damaging
to China's economy.
And I think they know that.
You know, I can't tell you that at the end
of this year we'll be able to say they made
the move we hoped they would make.
I can tell you that we're going to engage
with them at high levels on a consistent basis
to keep pressing forward, making the case,
and I believe that's welcome.
When I was in China just a few weeks ago,
you know, it was important for the president
to meet with us, to meet with me.
You know, we had an exchange that was our
second exchange in the time I've been secretary.
And when I meet with my counterpart, the vice
premier, we talk about the tough issues.
And they don't tell us to stay out of their
business.
They want to learn from our economic experience.
I think our continuing to bring focus to these
issues is something that helps them to make
progress.
But I approach it in a very clearheaded way.
Intentions are critical, and they're important,
that it's results in the end that matter.
BUSSEY: Well, one of the pressures that might
be brought to bear on China and Europe are
these two new trade agreements that are being
negotiated now, the TTIP in Asia -- Trans-Pacific
Partnership in Asia, and TTIP in Europe.
Can you get those trade agreements without
fast-track authority from Congress?
These countries don't want to be negotiating
with congresspeople.
They want to be negotiating with an administration
that can promise them that the deal that they're
striking is actually the deal that's going
to be put into force.
LEW: Well, I think we've made it clear that
we think fast-track authority is important,
and it's something we are going to work with
the Congress on.
As far as the negotiations go, I remember
when we started working on the Trans-Pacific
Partnership, TPP, back in 2009.
And there were skeptics who said, you can't
start a conversation setting high standards
with some of the smaller countries in the
region and think that the big countries are
going to join.
You look at where we are now, the big countries
are at the table, and even bigger countries
are contemplating coming to the table.
BUSSEY: Japan, yeah.
LEW: Japan is at the table, and China has,
you know, mused out loud about, should they
come to the table?
That is an enormous change from 2009.
so I think the principle of setting high-quality
standards as being the terms of the future
of trade relations in the Pacific and the
Atlantic has already moved very far.
There are still tough issues to be negotiated.
You know, I've never been a trade negotiator.
I would defer to people who've been successful
trade negotiators in the past.
The tough issues are always resolved at the
end.
It's not as if any party is going to, before
the final round of negotiations, make the
things that are really difficult for them
at home.
So we've got to keep driving forward, getting
to those final tough issues.
And we have to lock in both trade agreements
and fast-track authority.
We need to do both.
BUSSEY: Let's -- let's get to some questions.
And if I could just ask you to identify yourself
and who you're with.
Yes, please?
QUESTION: Hi, Nelson Cunningham with McLarty
Associates.
Mr. Secretary, good to see you.
Thank you for doing this.
Last year, in the president's budget, for
the first time that I can recall, a Democratic
president began to propose changes in the
growth of entitlement programs, designed to
rein in that growth.
Did it disappoint you that that conversation
was not picked up by the other side?
And would you expect the president's budget
this year to re-propose and try to start that
conversation once again?
LEW: Look, I think we ended the year and begin
this year in a place where we've made some
small progress, but important progress, getting
back to a more normal way of Congress doing
fiscal policy, making budgets.
And I think that's very important.
Obviously, we started a year in a place where
people were talking about a grand bargain.
The president put out a budget that did have
very tough policies in it that are hard in
terms of making changes to entitlement programs.
He also had a tax reform proposal that would've
raise revenues, so in a balanced way, we would've
been able to put in place what was really
at the core of earlier negotiations that he
had been having with Republican leaders.
I -- having worked on these issues for most
of the last 30 years -- would have hoped that
we could have reached an agreement, because
I thought then -- and I continue to think
-- that would be in the best interest of our
long-term fiscal path, our long-term economic
path.
I think that, you know, the president's budget
will speak for itself in just a few weeks.
I'm not going to get ahead of him announcing
any of his specific policies.
But I think he demonstrated last year in his
budget that he was -- remained committed to
a fair and balanced approach to having long-term
fiscal policies that keep us on the right
path.
And I think that, you know, last year's budget
reflected a deep -- a deep set of convictions.
BUSSEY: Yes, please, in the back here.
QUESTION: Secretary, David Sanger from the
New York Times.
Good to see you.
I wanted to ask you about China and cyber,
a big issue when the Sunnylands summit came
up and a continuing issue at your economic
and strategic dialogue.
There's a sense that the Snowden revelations
have sort of taken the pressure off of the
Chinese.
It has given them a way to argue -- whether
you believe the argument or not -- that we're
doing something akin to what they're doing
and there's very little evidence that you
see much of an abatement of the kind of behavior
that you were so concerned about, about this
time last year.
So I was wondering if you could give us a
sense of where that is going?
LEW: So, David, I have to push back on the
premise a bit.
I don't think there's any way to compare the
kinds of intelligence activities that almost
every country engages in for national security
purposes with the deliberate theft of trade
secrets for commercial advantage.
There's no comparison.
I don't think that anyone credibly believes
that there is a comparison, and I don't think
that the issue has in any way been taken off
the table in terms of our conversation with
the Chinese.
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE)
LEW: You know, we have been very clear.
I can't -- I can't tell you that -- that they
have done an about-face.
But I also think they understand that for
them to play the role that they want to play
in the world, as one of the great powers,
as one of the rule-makers for the world, you
can't be a rule-maker and engage in those
kinds of practices.
BUSSEY: Yes, in the back here.
QUESTION: Barry Wood, RTHK in Hong Kong.
Mr. Secretary, what about the IMF, money for
the IMF, the overdue payments that all of
the other countries talk about?
And what about boosting the representation
of developing countries, emerging markets
within the IMF?
It's moved at a snail's pace.
What's your view on that?
LEW: I think that the United States' commitment
to the IMF remains solid.
We're the biggest contributor and participant
in the IMF.
It's critically important to U.S. economic
well-being that the IMF be strong and that
we have the kind of role in it that we've
had since its inception after World War II.
In 2010, there was a negotiation which I think
made very important progress in terms of rebalancing
some of the shares of interest in the IMF,
while maintaining the U.S. position with a
significant enough share to have a controlling
voice on important questions.
I have made no secret of the fact that I think
it's critical for us to finalize the ratification
of those.
We made a full-court press to get it done
and got close, but didn't get it done this
past week.
We are continuing to stand by our commitment,
and we will get it done.
BUSSEY: Yes, please, right here.
QUESTION: Thanks.
Elisa Massimino with Human Rights First.
My question is about the role of money in
the supply chains that enable mass atrocities,
like those that are going on in Syria.
Some people have argued that -- including
some former Treasury officials -- that the
Treasury ought to take stronger action against
Russian banks that are involved directly in
financing arms shipments to Assad.
I wonder what you think about that and if
-- I know it can be awkward, since we're now
partners with Russia in trying to resolve
the situation, but do you think Treasury ought
to be taking stronger action in investigating
and even designating Russian banks that are
directly involved in supporting Assad?
LEW: We -- you know, through our responsibilities
in overseeing the flows of financial funds
and whether or not there is compliance with
U.S. and international laws with regard to
them, we have been very aggressive following
the flow of funds.
And when things violate the law, we take action
without regard to the home country of the
financial institution.
It doesn't always make us popular.
Sometimes it's friends who are very close;
sometimes it's countries with whom we have
more tension.
But, you know, our policy, whether it's sanctions
regarding Syria or Iran or other designated
countries, the designations aren't all the
same, but our policy is to be vigilant in
using these financial tools.
So I would just say that we implement these
laws and we don't look at the country of origin.
BUSSEY: Yes, please?
QUESTION: Father Andrew from the St. Paul's
Foundation.
Thank you so much for your government service,
Mr. Secretary, particularly for Tip O'Neill.
I grew up in the district.
St. Paul's distributes alms to the poor all
over the world, in 30 different countries,
in areas of severe conflict.
I want to touch back on OFAC.
There seems to be an extreme level -- or extreme
lack of accountability among the federal officers
at OFAC.
We can't get a name, we can't get a number
when we're trying to provide food, shelter,
clothing to people in refugee camps outside
of Syria.
We're trying to make financial transfers.
Our banks have a question for OFAC, we have
a conversation with OFAC.
We can't seem to get anybody at the table.
How would you propose building in accountability
so that we can provide these needed resources
to people who have the opportunity to be fanatics
and fundamentalists, but aren't, precisely
because of the alms and the aid that we're
giving them?
LEW: You know, I think OFAC does an outstanding
job in very difficult circumstances.
And there are often cases that are just heart-wrenching
in terms of flows of funds that are inconsistent
with our laws, but that have the effect of
providing relief at the same time.
Not just in Syria, it comes up in many troubled
parts of the world.
I'm happy to look into the question of access
and communication.
Obviously, we strive to a high level of clarity
But sometimes these issues relate to specific
matters that are not public matters.
And I would have to go and look at the specific
matter in order to respond.
QUESTION: There is a General License 11A.
BUSSEY: Yes, please.
Back here.
Yes.
QUESTION: Thank you.
Good morning.
Paula Stern, Stern Group.
My question's about the trade promotion authority.
And the headline yesterday in one of the papers
about the pushback from the Democrats.
We will need bipartisan approval of authority
for fast-track.
And given the fact that we started the year
with this new budget and deal in Congress,
which suggests that maybe we're not going
to be as toxic this year as -- as the past,
I'm wondering what your plans are, really,
for whipping into place a bipartisan authority
for the president, given the pushback from
some of the Democrats?
LEW: I don't think there's anything new or
unusual about the current need for there to
be bipartisan support for trade promotion
authority in order for it to pass.
That's always required a bipartisan effort.
There's always been challenges on both sides
for different reasons.
You know, we have worked on a bipartisan basis
with the leaders of the committees, and we'll
continue to work on a bipartisan basis with
the Congress to get it done.
The president has made clear that it's important.
It's one of those issues where there is the
ability for there to be a bipartisan conversation.
And it's never easy, so it's going to require
effort.
BUSSEY: Do you care to venture an estimate
-- the question about a timeframe on this
one?
(CROSSTALK)
BUSSEY: And on resolution of TPP and TTIP?
LEW: I, obviously, am very hopeful that the
next round of discussions on TPP really accelerates
the pace of progress, and that will have implications
in terms of other schedules.
So we'll have to see how the pace goes.
BUSSEY: Six months, 12 months?
LEW: I'm not going to put a number on it.
Obviously, Ambassador Froman has been pushing.
He pushed to have the meeting at the end of
last year be an issue where the final issues
get raised.
He's going to continue pressing so that those
issues, those hard issues that require countries
to kind of move across the finish line get
queued up.
And I believe it will happen.
BUSSEY: Ambassador Froman, the U.S. trade
representative...
LEW: U.S. trade representative.
BUSSEY: Yes, please, right here.
QUESTION: Twenty years ago, Jim Baker engineered
the Plaza Agreement.
And with the devaluation of the dollar, it
stabilized our current accounts for almost
10 years.
Recently, the Japanese have engineered a 20
percent devaluation of their currency.
Would you expect it to have a similar impact
on Japan's trade account?
And how will the South Koreans and others
react to this new change in their competitiveness?
LEW: You know, I think the challenges facing
Japan and their economy have been profound
for almost two decades.
I think, you know, it has been a recurring
argument made by the United States, the international
community that Japan needed to take action
to reverse almost two decades of deflation
and economic decline.
You know, they have put in place policies.
We still have to see what the so-called third
arrow of their policies are.
Those are the real reforms that will determine
whether or not the future is one where they'll
grow their domestic economy, grow domestic
demand, and be able to continue to have the
kind of growth that they're now seeing because
of the shorter-term policies they've put into
effect.
I think it was very important that last year,
roughly this time, in February, there was
an agreement at the G-7 and the G-20 that
has stuck, which is that countries will be
-- hold themselves to the agreed-upon rule
that they will use domestic tools for domestic
purposes to grow their economy.
That is a critically important frame, and
it's something that Japan has to stick to.
You know, they need to get their domestic
economy growing.
Their long-term growth can't be rooted in
a strategy that ultimately turns in any way
towards, you know, reliance on unfair advantage
because of exchange rate.
You know, we have kept an eye on that.
Our currency report analyzed it very closely.
We continue to analyze it very closely.
And we said, as long as they stick to those
rules, domestic tools for domestic purposes,
it's in Japan's interests and the world's
interests for Japan's economy to grow.
You know, the three big -- you know, four
big economies of the world are the United
States, Europe, China and Japan.
If any one of them is performing particularly
sub-par, it creates problems that flow well
beyond the borders.
And there's a balance where -- you know, we've
got to keep an eye on it.
We can't let it turn from the kinds of policies
that are domestic policies for domestic purposes,
but it is important for Japan, also, to grow.
BUSSEY: So we have two minutes' time for just
one more question, right down here, the back
of the room.
QUESTION: Thank you very much.
My name is Chi Mi Nguyen (ph) with Voice of
Vietnamese Americans.
Thank you, Secretary.
I come back to your focus on standards and
implementation.
And I'd like to hear from you the lessons
learned from our WTO and the coming TPP and
TTIPs and other free trade agreements, because
I think there's a lot of doubt and uncertainty
in our (inaudible) regarding the unemployment
that we've been experiencing for the last
5 years, actually for the last 10 years.
You see, since the WTO, we have suffered the
currency war and many other wars with rising
power China.
And the recent still anti-dumping situation
with the WTO that's happened threatened our
industry and our market.
So our question to you is, as the treasurer,
secretary of treasury, where do you see we
need to do to ensure the implementation phase
of our agreements to secure our currency and
our jobs?
Thank you, for the U.S., for the Americans.
LEW: Yeah, I think we have been very clear
in all of our conversations, in the multilateral
negotiations and our bilateral conversations,
that we need a level playing field with clear
rules, and those rules need to be enforced.
So taking enforcement actions to make sure
that the agreements are adhered to is a critical
part of having effective rules of the road.
Rules that aren't followed aren't really rules.
So that's why WTO actions are brought from
time to time.
And the goal is to have countries observe
the rules, not to be in a place where one
has to be taking actions to -- whether it's
for one industry or another -- to enforce
the rules.
I think that if you go back to what I was
saying a few minutes ago, in terms of the
spirit of the negotiation of TPP, it's very
encouraging.
You know, I was just recently in Asia, went
to a range of countries with extremely different
economies.
I was in Japan, China, Malaysia, Vietnam,
and Singapore.
In each of the countries, at a very different
point of internal economic development, there
was a desire to participate in a high-standard
trade agreement.
There was also anxiety about, what did that
mean in terms of the domestic economy?
What would be the transition rules?
What would be the reflection of the fact that
countries don't come in exactly the same position?
And those are the kinds of issues that are
being negotiated in the TPP with a sensitivity
to the fact that if we get all of the countries
to credible and enforceable, high-level rules,
it's good for each of us individually and
it's good for us globally.
But it's not good if the rules are broken
and we need to be vigilant as we are to make
sure that, when we make agreements, the agreements
are kept.
BUSSEY: Secretary Lew, you've got to get to
work before the stock market opens at 9:30,
so I want to -- I want to thank you and -- for
joining us today and also thank the Council
on Foreign Relations for holding this event.
LEW: Thank you very much, John.
BUSSEY: Thanks very much.
(APPLAUSE)
END